et vous remercie chaleureusement pour
cette audition qui permettra je l'espère
d'éclairer nos membres sur les mesures
prévues dans le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
rectificatif et sur leurs impacts en
particulier sur les femmes avant de
passer à notre ordre du jour
permettez-moi de faire un petit point
traditionnel sur l'agenda le mercredi 15
février à 16h30 notre délégation
auditionnera Madame Agnès firmalobodo
ministre délégué auprès du ministre de
la Santé de la prévention chargée de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé c'est audition se
substitue à celle d'Isabelle Rome qui
est décalée au mois de mars après la
tenue du comité inter ministérielle
égalité nous aurons également le jeudi 2
mars toujours en plénière et dans le
cadre de la mission d'information budget
j'en Rey une table ronde avec des
représentants des collectivités
territoriales ayant mis en place cette
démarche elle sera organisée dans ce
cadre là je rappelle une invitation
auprès de vous tous pour aller
rechercher des initiatives dans vos
territoires pour permettre de nourrir
cette audition nous souhaitons que ce
que cette mission soit vraiment nourrie
des expérimentations qui sont dans vos
circonscriptions et n'hésitez pas à
nourrir ce débat je vous rappelle en
outre que la délégation organise le
premier mars et en lien avec la
présidente de l'Assemblée dans le cadre
de la séquence du 8 mars une journée
d'atelier qui sera sur la mixité nous
recevrons trois classes de lycéens de
l'Essonne on organise le matin des
ateliers puis on aura un temps de
restitution de ces ateliers de 16h à 18h
en salle Victor Hugo vous êtes
chaleureusement convié à participer dans
le traitement des ateliers on traite le
sujet de l'éducation la lutte contre les
stéréotypes de genre et nous tétons
évidemment des sujets orientation
formation donc à nouveau je vous invite
à participer à la fois peut-être aux
ateliers le matin et surtout sur la sur
la restitution en fin de journée enfin
vous pouvez d'ores et déjà noter à votre
agenda la date du 2 mai
2023 17h30 nous organisons la projection
du documentaire lettre à l'enfant que tu
m'as donné de Charlotte Silvera cette
projection sera suivie d'une table ronde
en présence de notre ministre Isabelle
Rome nous en arrivons maintenant à notre
ordre du jour nous allons entendre une
présentation par Monsieur le Ministre
des principaux en jeu et des impacts sur
la réforme de la réforme pardon pour les
femmes je donnerai ensuite la parole aux
orateurs de groupe pour une durée de 2
minutes je vous demanderai de bien
vouloir respecter ce temps je donne le
temps global nous sommes ensemble
jusqu'à 18h15 donc nous serons nous
ferons en sorte que chacun puisse
intervenir à l'issue de ce temps je
donnerai la parole à des questions
brèves et on va tenter de faire des
questions réponses pour essayer de
dynamiser ce
cet échange et se débat donc le temps le
respect du temps sera crucial pour être
dans notre timing je vous remercie mes
chers collègues monsieur le ministre
vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
quelques
mots d'abord pour vous remercier de
cette invitation à présenter ce qui
concerne plus particulièrement la
situation des femmes et la question de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
dans la réforme des retraites telles que
nous l'avons présenté dans le cadre du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale rectif que la
commission des affaires sociales examine
actuellement et qui sera examinée en
séance à partir de la semaine prochaine
il y a cette occasion qui m'est donnée
mais c'est aussi pour moi l'occasion de
rappeler que la question de l'égalité
professionnelle et de l'égalité des
femmes et des hommes dans chacun des
secteurs du travail tant la vie active
qu'après la vie active au moment de la
retraite doit être une préoccupation
constante c'est une préoccupation
constante de mon ministère je crois que
c'est une préoccupation qui est
évidemment très largement partagée par
l'ensemble des membres de votre
délégation nous sommes souvent dans le
débat qui nous anime autour des
retraites confronter une forme de
difficulté ou en tout cas
d'interrogation de recherche de
solutions qu'il a aussi je crois peut
traverser différentes sensibilités qui
animent le Parlement et votre délégation
nous souhaitons toutes et tous que le
système de retraite soit le plus
protecteur possible et nous avons toutes
et tous une forme de tentation mais qui
ne tentation extrêmement humaine
extrêmement compréhensible de faire en
sorte que ce système de retraite en
particulier puisse corriger gommer par
son âme effacer un certain d'inégalités
d'injustice qui est tout au long de la
vie on puisse s'accumuler et je pense
notamment cette injustice qui persiste
en matière de vie professionnelle et ce
chantier toujours ouvert de l'égalité
professionnelle puisque nous savons que
c'est ce sont les inégalités
professionnelles qui font les inégalités
de retraite et que ce sont ces
inégalités professionnelles qui
expliquent l'écart moyen de pension
entre les femmes et les hommes ce n'est
pas le système de retraite en lui-même
qui génère cette inégalité mais bien les
années qui le précèdent et que parfois
nous essayons de réparer le système de
retraite n'est donc pas responsable en
lui-même par les paramètres qui sont les
siens de cette situation et d'ailleurs
nous pouvons voir qu'avec la progression
l'augmentation
continue permanente tant du taux
d'emploi que de la capacité à concilier
10 personnels vie familiale dit
professionnel et donc une augmentation
du taux d'emploi des femmes à la fois
par génération mais aussi à l'échelle de
toute une vie progressivement et
malheureusement très lentement les
inégalités de Menton de pension entre
les femmes et les hommes diminuent
beaucoup trop doucement évidemment mais
nous étions à plus de 40% et à quelques
années nous sommes aujourd'hui à 30%
c'est évidemment considérable évidemment
inacceptable mais cela démontre aussi
que sociologiquement le fait que notre
société permet certaines manières
facilite je ne sais comment l'exprimer
un travail des femmes à l'échelle d'une
vie plus facile ou en tout cas moins
difficile à concilier avec une vie
personnelle et une vie familiale a aussi
pour conséquence que nous puissions
avancer en matière de réduction des
inégalités il y a trois points que je
voudrais expliciter devant vous pour
peut-être faire écho un certain nombre
de débats qui ont pu traverser l'espace
public au cours des derniers jours le
système la réforme de retraite que nous
présentons n'est d'abord pas une réforme
défavorable aux femmes c'est une
évidence à nos yeux je vais essayer de
l'expliquer et peut-être même de
convaincre et nous mettons même en place
même en place pardon des dispositions
qui sont protectrices pour les femmes
les plus fragiles en tout cas celles qui
sont les plus exposées aux difficultés
professionnelles que j'évoquais il y a
un instant
ce texte que nous vous présentons
syntaxe qui est a été enrichi amélioré
je crois au style de la concertation à
la fois par ces aspects généraux mais
aussi par des échanges parfois plus
thématiques et je tiens à souligner
d'ailleurs à ce sujet la qualité des
échanges entre
nous-mêmes madame la Présidente dans les
échanges que nous avons directement vos
équipes et les miennes ou encore avec
Madame panonet autour d'un certain
nombre de sujets et je pense notamment
aux avancées qui ont pu être d'ores et
déjà imaginer et que le gouvernement
soutient pour faire en sorte par exemple
que sur l'index des seniors il puisse y
avoir une approche genre de cette index
des seniors vous avez déposé un
amendement ce sens qui nous paraît utile
pour avoir la bonne mesure et donc les
bons outils pour répondre à tous
je voudrais revenir en premier point sur
la question de l'âge de départ et
de la durée d'activité nécessaire pour
faire valoir une retraite à taux plein
le fait que les femmes soient amenées à
repousser leur âge de départ après la
réforme s'explique de deux manières
comme pour les hommes ça s'explique à la
fois par la mise en application de la
réforme votée en 2013 avec un relèvement
de la durée de cotisation minimale
exigée pour avoir droit à une retraite à
taux plein et ça s'explique évidemment
par le fait que nous envisageons de
relever progressivement l'âge
d'ouverture des droits de 62 à 64 ans et
il y a une forme de conséquence
mécanique à cela avec
un âge au départ qui va évoluer tant
pour les femmes que pour les hommes je
tiens à préciser et vous retrouvez cet
élément dans l'étude d'impact en tout
cas dans le rapport de d'évaluation que
nous avons remis en page 56 pour être
tout à fait précis alors nous parlons
pour la génération 60 61 62 61 plus
particulièrement cette génération qui
peut faire valoir ces droits à la
retraite au moment où nous nous
réunissons là je départ effectif je ne
parle pas je ne parle pas d'âge légal de
départ mais là je de départ
effectivement et le même que celui des
hommes pendant très longtemps là je n'ai
pas reflectif des femmes a été
supérieure à celui des hommes du fait
d'une propension subie à avoir des
carrières hachées et donc à connaître
des cariachées qui amené les femmes à
travailler plus longtemps après l'âge
d'ouverture des droits pour atteindre le
taux plein et d'ailleurs parce qu'on
regarde lesquels des assurés sont les
plus nombreux à devoir aller jusqu'à 67
ans et donc là je suis pression de la
décote c'est très majoritairement des
femmes et c'est pour cela que nous avons
fait le choix de maintenir là je suis
pression de la décote à 67 ans alors que
chacune des réformes précédentes de
relèvement de la ouverture des droits
c'était aussi traduite par un relèvement
à du concurrence de l'âge de suppression
de la décote et donc nous avions cette
situation où là je moyens de départ
effectivement des supérieurs aujourd'hui
nous sommes sur un âge qui est un
effectif qui est le même et lorsqu'on le
regarde ce rapport d'évaluation à
l'étude d'impact on voit que
progressivement lorsqu'on avance dans le
temps l'âge de départ effectif des
femmes va progressivement être inférieur
à celui des hommes c'est ce qui m'a
amené à quelques occasions de souligner
qu'en 2030 pour prendre un horizon qui
n'est pas trop lointain là je n'ai pas
effectifs des femmes sera inférieure à
celui des hommes alors qu'il est
identique aujourd'hui
c'est un premier point que je voulais
souligner car en 2000 les femmes
pardonnez-moi en 1972 pour les français
né en 1972 l'âge de départ effectifs
estimé dans l'ensemble des études sur
lesquelles nous appuyons sera de 64 ans
lors de ce départ effectif pour les
femmes et de 180 mois pour pour les
hommes je répète c'est la double
conséquence à la fois du relèvement de
l'âge et de la mise en oeuvre de la
réforme dit Touraine d'augmentation de
la durée de cotisation se pose parfois
la question et c'est en cela qu'il y a
un chantier à mon sens devant nous de la
manière dont sont valorisés à la fin de
la carrière les trimestres qui sont
l'objet d'une validation et qui sont
considérés comme validées mais non
cotisés à l'occasion d'événements
familiaux le fait de relever quelque peu
là je départ le fait d'augmenter la
durée de cotisation exigée amène à une
forme de moindre effet de ces trimestres
validés à l'occasion d'une maternité ou
de l'éducation d'un enfant à peu près
tout à fait complet sur les huit
trimestres que l'on peut appliquer dans
le cas du régime général et cela
s'explique aussi par le fait que parce
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure le fait
que aujourd'hui beaucoup beaucoup pour
ne pas dire la plupart ça serait un peu
présomptueux de dire beaucoup ou toute
la plupart des femmes qui travaillent
qui ont un enfant
peuvent à la fois reprendre une activité
rapidement sont indemniser dans le cadre
du congé maternité et donc à l'occasion
d'une naissance peuvent à la fois la
même année valider un certain nombre de
trimestres titre de leur activité
professionnelle et de leurs revenus et
dans le même temps bénéficier et c'est
la loi qui le prévoit ainsi de 4
trimestres validés supplémentaires et
nous sommes passés d'une situation
ou de ce que nous avons créé
je vois madame régir mais je vais au
bout de la démonstration parce que je
peux peut-être même qu'on fait d'accord
sur l'objectif final mais lorsque c'est
trimestre validé ont été décidées à la
fin des années 60 nous étions dans une
situation où parce qu'une femme avait un
enfant et accouché elle a arrêté son
activité et c'est trimestre c'était
véritablement pensé comme une
compensation de trimestre pendant
lesquels elle ne pouvait pas cotiser et
parce qu'elle ne pouvait pas travailler
qu'elle ne bénéficie pas de revenus de
substitution suffisant pour valider les
trimestres et nous sommes passés ce qui
est plutôt heureux à une situation où
les évolutions que j'évoquais et donc le
permettant cette trimestre vienne
prendre plus et non pas en compensation
en contrepartie de trimestre entre
guillemets perdu parce que non cotisés
et donc c'est une question que nous
devons peut-être regarder de manière
très posée très rationnelle si vous
permettez cette expression à la fois
pour trouver de l'égalité parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons des régimes en
la matière qui sont totalement
différents le fait que dans le régime
général il y a quatre trimestres
validées alors que dans la fonction
publique il y en ait deux peut
interroger le fait qu'il le dispositif
concernant les quatre trimestres
supplémentaires dit d'éducation d'un
enfant soit librement répartie entre les
deux parents mais à condition de le
faire avant 4 ans et demi souffre d'un
déficit d'information qui est manifeste
et le fait que cette trimestre viennent
désormais en plus et non pas en
contrepartie peut nous interroger et pas
pour les remettre en cause pas pour
mettre en cause l'idée même et pour nous
demander si notre système de droit
familiaux répond véritablement aux
objectifs que lui qu'on lui donne et
peut-être que nous sommes passés et
c'est une réflexion que nous pouvons
avoir d'un objectif où c'est très mastré
validé venez remplacer et compenser donc
des trimestres non cotisés perdus à une
situation désormais la parentalité en
l'occurrence la maternité n'empêche plus
de cotiser au moment de l'arrivée de
l'enfant mais peut-être perçu comme un
frein à l'évolution professionnelle et
si c'est un frein à l'évolution
professionnelle ce qu'on sait que dans
différentes études c'est le cas
ça n'est pas forcément par l'octroi de
trimestre de compensation mais peut-être
par d'autres mécanismes et je le dis
très très très très directement d'autres
mécanismes inventé que l'on peut
apporter des réponses à cette inégalité
de déroulement de carrière lié parfois à
la maternité qui ne se traduit plus par
une absence d'être cotisée mais plutôt
par un frein à la promotion
professionnelle ou à la progression
professionnelle
ça fait partie du chantier sur les
droits familiaux qu'elle nous proposons
d'ouvrir à la fois avec le corps mais je
sais et votre délégation très
certainement de manière prioritaire
l'intérêt des parlementaires sur ce
sujet là la deuxième chose que je veux
souligner concerne la question du niveau
des pensions
près de une fois la réforme votée si
elle l'est bien évidemment par le
Parlement près 30 fois près de 30% des
femmes qui partiront à leur retraite
verront leur pension augmenter grâce aux
dispositions de la réforme contre un peu
plus de 15% des hommes là aussi ça ne
s'explique pas par une disposition qui
se serait spécifiquement adressée aux
femmes dans cette réforme ça s'explique
par le fait que les mécanismes que nous
mettons en place notamment sur le
minimum de retraite à 85% du SMIC vont
bénéficier directement et
prioritairement aux assurés qui
aujourd'hui partent à la retraite avec
les pensions les plus basses et que la
part des femmes dans ces assurés qui
partent avec les pensions les plus
basses est évidemment surpendérante
sur-représenté du fait des inégalités
professionnelles accumulées tout au long
de la vie et donc le fait de relever le
minimum de pension bénéficie mais le
terme est impropre apporte un effet
positif sur le niveau de retraite des
femmes plus que sur celui des hommes
tout simplement parce que ces femmes les
femmes en question sont aujourd'hui
celles qui ont les plus petites pensions
et donc il est logique que un tel
relèvement leur profits plus directement
il y aura donc une forme de réduction
des inégalités de Jarre et c'est heureux
mais je crois que nous reviendrons là
aussi à la question de l'égalité
professionnelle je disais il y avait 40
% de d'écart entre la pension moyenne
des femmes et celles des hommes
aujourd'hui nous sommes autour de 30 %
un peu au-dessus de 30 % et l'objectif
évidemment cette inégalité de niveau de
pension soit totalement supprimé et pour
qu'elle soit totalement supprimée cela
passe évidemment par une égalité
professionnelle réelle tout au long de
la carrière et là aussi le chantier
reste ouvert enfin il y a un certain
nombre de dispositions ils ont terminé
par là qui permettent une amélioration
de la prise en compte de la situation
des femmes
d'abord en prenant en compte les congés
parentaux et plus globalement les
trimestres acquis au titre de
l'assurance vieillesse des parents au
foyer pour un certain nombre de
dispositifs c'est ainsi que nous allons
intégrer un certain nombre de trimestre
cotisé au titre de l'assurance
vieillesse pour les parents foyer pour
les éligibilité au dispositif des
carrières longues et des retraites
minimales jusqu'à 4 trimestres et par
ailleurs ces trimestre rentreront de
manière intégrale tous les trimestres
dans le calcul du minimum de pension ce
qui n'était pas le cas jusqu'à l'heure
et là aussi nous avons un objectif qui
est tant pour les carrières longues que
pour le calcul des minimum de pension de
faire en sorte que cette intégration de
trimestre validé au titre de la VPF soit
de nature à supporter et à mieux aider
les femmes les assurés femmes qui ont le
niveau de pension le plus élevé
la deuxième mesure mais je l'ai évoqué
je passe rapidement c'est évidemment le
maintien de l'âge du taux plein et donc
de là je suppression de la décote
puisque le fait que l'écart en classe
d'ouverture des droits et cet âge soit
ramené à trois ans et alors qu'il a
toujours été à 5 ans amen finalement une
possibilité de limiter les effets de la
décote et que ça profite prioritairement
à celles et ceux qui ont les carrières
les plus hachées
je termine ma dernière présidente en me
disant que sur ces trois points il y a
évidemment à chaque fois je pense des
avancées soit des outils pour conforter
des situations mais que dans les
responsabilités qui sont les miennes
aujourd'hui au delà de cette réforme des
retraites à chaque fois que je pourrais
être à vos côtés pour permettre de
rétablir cette égalité professionnelle
entre les femmes et les hommes et ainsi
réduire les inégalités qui en découlent
lors du départ à la retraite vous
pourrez bien évidemment compter sur mon
concours
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
avant de donner la parole à nos
collègues orateurs permettez-moi de vous
poser la première question si la réforme
comporte vous l'avez indiqué de
nombreuses garanties en ce qui concerne
les cariérarchies ou les aidants
et finalement qui permet d'excès
d'excentuer pardon la résorption
progressive des écarts entre les
pensions des femmes et celles des hommes
il n'en reste pas moins que selon le
l'étude d'impact on a un écart qui
resterait 18,3% pour les générations qui
sont nées en 80 et bien que ce chiffre
vous l'avez dit soit en baisse nous ne
pouvons nous en satisfaire s'agissant
des pensions qui seront versées
finalement dans plus de 20 ans donc je
pense que nous devrions prendre
l'objectif à l'horizon d'une génération
2050 d'éradiquer totalement l'écart de
pension entre les femmes et les hommes
c'est pourquoi je souhaite que le
gouvernement prenne ce sujet à bras le
corps en agissant cette fois-ci
peut-être sur le marché du travail vous
l'avez dit
en amont finalement de de qui permettent
ces conséquences là et d'agir sur trois
causes la première c'est la
discrimination salariale de continuer à
travailler sur les inégalités de salaire
à toute chose également
la question de la mixité des métiers en
particulier dans les filières les plus
portesuses les plus rémunératrices et je
cite les secteur du numérique par
exemple les femmes allant plus
spontanément
moins spontanément plutôt sur des
filières qui sont plus rémunératrices et
enfin la question de la moindre
participation des femmes au marché du
travail on le sait du fait de choix
familiaux maternité parentalité
évidemment dans les familles elles sont
plus facilement des aides
dans les familles monsieur le ministre
quel levier entendez-vous mobiliser pour
atteindre ses objectifs
d'abord peut-être un mot madame la
Présidente pour vous dire que vous avez
évoqué les aidants je n'ai pas évoqué
dans dans mon propos mais vous avez bien
fait puisque effectivement le texte
permet prévoit plutôt la création d'une
assurance vieillesse pour les aidons et
que c'est une volonté d'aider les
aidants de soutenir les aidants de
reconnaître leur implication et c'est
une mesure qui là aussi non pas parce
qu'elle est pensé pour les femmes mais
parce que souvent les femmes sont des
aidants plutôt que les aidants ne sont
souvent les aidants sont des aidantes va
bénéficier dans sa mise en oeuvre plus
aux femmes qu'aux hommes du fait de
cette forme de répartition des tâches et
nous le faisons pour là aussi
reconnaître cette implication auprès des
proches blessés malades ou en situation
de handicap sur l'objectif de
d'inégalité 0 en tout cas une égalité
totale entre les pensions de retraite
des hommes et des femmes horizons 2050
nous y vont et nous souscrivons à une
forme à une condition mais vous l'avez
évoqué c'est que ce soit accompagné d'un
plan d'action la déclaration l'intention
et l'objectif je pense sont partagés par
tous et si nous pouvions en faire plus
vite nous en serions tous très heureux
mais il faut que nous puissions avoir ce
plan d'action et les pistes que vous
avez tracées notamment sur un centre de
secteur qui ne sont pas encore
suffisamment féminisés aujourd'hui sont
évidemment des pistes sur lesquels nous
travaillons tout comme sur l'accès au
marché du travail ou encore sur le
développement de nouvelles d'une
nouvelle offre de service en matière de
petite enfance et de garde d'enfants
puisqu'on sait que dans les principaux
freins à l'accès à l'emploi ou à la
mobilité la question de la garde
d'enfant est tout à fait prépondérante
et notamment pour les femmes qui élève
seule leurs enfants donc ça fait partie
des sujets sur lesquels nous sommes à la
fois ouvert au travail mais aussi ouvert
au partage de ce que nous avons déjà
imaginé ce sur quoi nous avons déjà
avancé sur les questions de garde
d'enfant en particulier mon collègue
Jean-Christophe kobb compte pardon dans
le cadre des déclinaisons du Conseil
national de la refondation a ouvert un
certain nombre de chantiers qu'on pourra
partager avec vous
je vous remercie la parole pour le
groupe Renaissance et ta prise 4
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre effectivement comme vous l'avez
dit la question de l'impact de la
réforme des retraites sur les femmes et
cruciales et nous observons aujourd'hui
malheureusement beaucoup de
contre-vérités de désinformation à ce
sujet que je pense cette audition va
permettre de lever en sérénité j'ai bon
espoir que nous pourrons aborder avec
vous comme vous l'avez fait en préambule
déjà un certain nombre de scénarios qui
entourent cette question mais aussi et
surtout identifier les points où nous
pouvons peut-être aller plus loin même
au-delà de ce propre texte effectivement
vous l'avez rappelé ce texte présente
plusieurs avancées pour la retraite des
femmes il s'attache tout
particulièrement à protéger les femmes
qui ont des carrières hachées des
carrières interrompues celles qui
aujourd'hui ont souvent les plus petites
pensions ainsi près de 30% des femmes
bénéficieront d'une augmentation de leur
pension les situations d'interruption
d'activités seront mieux prises en
compte pour l'éligibilité aux carrières
longues au moment de la retraite mais
également dans le cadre des carrières de
retraite minimale et cela nous devons
souligner c'est une grande avancée par
ailleurs nous continuons d'enrichir ce
texte chaque jour en ce moment se
déroule l'étude de ce texte en
commission des affaires sociales et pour
toujours plus d'égalité nous avons
adopté en début de semaine l'amendement
portant sur l'obligation de distinguer
les sexes dans l'index seniors porté par
la députée Marie-Pierre Rixens cependant
le Conseil là de nombreuses inégalités
subsistent et les écarts de pension
s'expliquent en grande partie par les
écarts de salaire contre lesquels il
faut lutter mais soyons clairs le
système de retraite n'a pas vocation à
corriger l'intégralité des difficultés à
posteriorer ainsi au-delà de l'examen de
ce texte nous avons travaillé depuis 5
ans à corriger ces inégalités ces
défaillances du monde du travail dans la
continuité de cette réforme il serait
nécessaire et urgent de s'interroger sur
des actions au-delà de ce texte portant
sur notre système de retraite comme vous
l'avez tout justement dit en préambule
notamment sur la question d'une
politique des familles quelle solution
souhaitons-nous apporter au défi
démographique démographique à moyen et à
long terme quelle mesure prendre en
compte pour continuer à agir pour qu'une
femme n'est plus à choisir ou n'est pas
à choisir entre ça maternité et sa
carrière quelle solution enfin
avons-nous pour continuer à réduire les
écarts de salaire et les inégalités
professionnelles entre les hommes et les
femmes avons même d'arriver à ce moment
de la retraite ces questions je pense
que chacun d'entre nous a coeur d'y
répondre néanmoins nous devons
comprendre que l'ensemble de ces
problématiques ne peuvent rentrer
uniquement essentiellement dans le champ
du texte que nous examinons aujourd'hui
par conséquent monsieur le ministre je
connais l'engagement de votre ministère
pour combattre chaque jour les
inégalités entre les hommes et les
femmes et j'espère que vous pouvez vous
pourrez continuer à nous parler de ce
sujet sur les peut-être prochaine
échéances à venir merci
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
peut-être tout simplement dire que une
grande surprise si je souscris largement
à propos de Madame Thévenot personne
n'en sera surpris même dire que dans des
différentes dispositions que nous
prenons il a un certain que j'ai évoqué
notamment le fait de mieux protéger les
carrières
c'est là aussi une mesure qui s'applique
à tous les assurés mais qui a des
conséquences peut-être plus importantes
pour les femmes qui sont plus exposées
ça a l'air pour l'intégration donc des
trimestres la VPF des trimestres de
congé parentaux tant pour les
éligibilité au carrément sur le calcul
de la durée de cotisation requise que
sur le calcul du minimum contributif
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est que de manière peut-être
plus technique dans les modalités que
nous avons retenues pour le calcul du
montant du minimum de pension et de son
éligibilité
nous disons et c'est une réalité que le
minimum de pension va se traduire par un
relèvement au 1er septembre de la
pension minimum pardon pour la
répétition de 200 euros sous forme de
relèvement du minimum contributif en
réalité il s'agit de relever le minimum
contributifs majoré de 75 euros et
minimum contributif de base de 25 ça
permet à la fois de relever puisque
c'est pour des carrières complètes là
l'objectif cible de relever très
fortement plus fortement la pension de
celle des ceux qui ont travaillé pendant
au moins 30 ans c'est le premier critère
d'éligibilité au micro majoré mais de
relever aussi la pension souvent assez
basse de ceux qui ont travaillé moins de
30 ans mais qui on peut connaître des
interruptions plus longues dans dans
leur carrière il y a d'autres leviers
que nous pouvons actionner il y a
évidemment un levier sur la question de
l'égalité professionnelle et c'est
d'assurer à la fois un suivi tous les
engagements qui ont été pris plusieurs
lois ont été votés il faut aller au bout
de celle-ci et lorsqu'on voit les
résultats de l'égalité de l'index
égalité professionnelle ils sont plutôt
encourageants puisque à méthodologie
constante et un mode de calcul constant
les notes des entreprises qui sont
exposées à cet indice sont des notes en
amélioration ce qui est plutôt
témoignage d'une bonne dynamique ça ne
veut pas dire que le schéma est terminé
mais la dynamique est là
il y a une politique d'accompagnement
nous devons mettre en place et renforcer
auprès des familles puisque la question
de la natalité est évidemment une
question majeure mais à concilier avec
la vie professionnelle je ne voudrais
pas pardon si je dis de manière
simpliste mais je ne connais pas qu'un
regain de politique de natalité se
traduisent par un déclin de politique en
matière d'égalité professionnelle et
d'accès à l'emploi des femmes donc il
faut faire attention à ces deux éléments
et puis il y a des éléments d'égalité
qu'on peut travailler le gouvernement
est tout près d'ici la séance à avancer
avec les parlementaires qui le
souhaitent sur la réduction de certaines
inégalités je pense par exemple au fait
que aujourd'hui les professions
libérales et elles sont nombreuses pas
nécessairement toujours avec des revenus
aussi importants que l'image qu'on en a
ne bénéficient pas de la majoration de
10% d'en bénéficient les autres assurés
à partir du troisième enfant ça fait
partie des choses que l'on peut regarder
aussi pour faire en sorte qu'il est le
maximum d'égalité
cette situation est d'autant plus unique
du fait que les femmes prennent déjà
leur tapis tard que les hommes elles
sont déjà 19% notamment issus du
baby-boom contre 10% des hommes à devoir
aller au-delà de 65 ans pour éviter une
décote en raison de carrière plus
souvent hachée bien sûr ces situations
sont aussi liées à la structure de
l'économie des dernières décennies qui a
causé des inégalités certaines
salariales entre les femmes et les
hommes et les gouvernances successives
n'y sont pas étrangères l'amélioration
des carrières féminines est la meilleure
prise en compte de la maternité tant
avant cette réforme à améliorer les
pensions de retraite à long terme des
femmes et rapprocher leur retraite
conjoncturelle de celle des hommes
pourquoi Monsieur le Ministre vouloir
casser cette dynamique de réduction
d'inégalités avec cette réforme pourquoi
prendre une fois de plus les femmes à
témoins et réduire l'effet de trimestre
pour la maternité alors même qu'elle est
une avancée majeure de ces dernières
années et que
concomitamment la natalité est au plus
bas historiquement en France je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre
merci madame monsieur le député je
crains que depuis votre place vous le
voyez très bien mais c'est le graphique
que j'évoquais et par ailleurs comme
tout le monde le verra pas aussi bien
que vous parce que vous êtes assez
proche mais collaborateurs n'ont autant
de copies que nécessaire si vous le
souhaitez mais au-delà de ça il est page
56 de l'étude d'impact et graphique
monte bien que pour la génération 1955
le départ effectif est à 52 ans et 3-4
mois pour les femmes alors qu'il était à
61 ans et 6 mois pour les hommes que ça
se rapproche de manière structurelle
jusque à la génération 61 62 63 ou
quelques semaines près dans un sens ou
dans un autre c'est le croisement des
courbes le départ à la retraite est un
âge effectif identique et ensuite c'est
le graphique tient compte de
l'application de la réforme le graphique
rouge et là j'effectif de départ des
femmes et page 56 habitudes d'impact
vous verrez que il y a même graphique
avec en plus une troisième courbe qui
lâche moyen et qu'en dessous dès qu'elle
est deux ans par évidence deux ans en
2030 il y a la même cour la même
évolution s'il n'y avait pas de réforme
et on voit que les courbes sont passées
parallèles et que cette abaissement de
l'âge effectif de départ des femmes par
rapport à celui des hommes vaut avec ou
sans réforme donc il n'y a pas de
dégradation de la situation des femmes
par contre et je le dis rapidement parce
que je l'ai déjà évoqué longuement tout
à l'heure
l'augmentation de l'âge de manière
générale ainsi que l'augmentation de la
durée de cotisation et le fait et je le
répète c'est une très bonne chose que la
carrée des femmes soit de plus en plus
complète doit nous interroger sur
l'utilité la pertinence de cette
validation trimestre supplémentaire dans
le cas justement où les femmes
concernées arrivent avoir une carrière
complète lorsqu'on de ce que les femmes
en question les femmes prennent des
enfants ont une carrière très lâchée la
validation des trimestres reste
intéressante parce qu'elle permet
effectivement d'atteindre la durée
régime requise lorsque la carrière
complète aujourd'hui comme demain
l'intérêt est beaucoup et bien moindre
et donc peut-être que dans le cadre de
la réflexion que j'ai évoquée on peut
trouver des manières d'accompagner de
rétablir l'égalité peut-être différente
mais ça reste véritablement à construire
les graphiques sont je crois assez
parlant au-delà de tout homme de
déclaration
merci pour elle et fille madame Sarah
Legrand
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre hier il y
avait du monde dans la rue contre votre
réforme vous savez presque 3 millions et
parmi eux j'ai vu une femme avec cette
pancarte je déprime moins en simulant
l'orgasme qu'en simulant ma retraite
pourquoi donc cette femme est elle si
déprimée de simuler sa retraite
peut-être que comme la moyenne des
femmes elle touche une pension située
sous le seuil de pauvreté et inférieur à
40% de 40% à celle de son voisin
masculin
ou alors peut-être que comme une femme
sur cinq elle devra travailler jusqu'à
67 ans pour ne pas subir la décote ou
encore peut-être qu'elle exerce l'un de
ces trois nombreux métiers féminisés
dont la médecine la pénibilité n'est pas
reconnue par exemple auxiliaire de vie
qui porte des cours c'est des personnes
à longueur de journée sans que cela soit
considéré comme une charge lourde
peut-être subit-elle un temps partiel
faute de solution gardant enfant
monsieur le ministre cette réalité vécue
par les femmes est déjà fort déprimante
et vous réussissez l'exploit de
l'aggraver encore avec votre réforme
avec votre réforme l'augmentation de la
durée de travail sera deux fois plus
forte pour les femmes que pour les
hommes c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
votre étude d'impact alors je vous
entends ici vous réjouir que leurs
pensions vont augmenter un peu j'ai
envie de vous dire c'est franchement la
moindre des choses en devant travailler
plus
et surtout par pitié n'ayez pas l'un des
sens de nous répondre encore minimum
contributif à 1200 euros brut ou encore
prise en compte de la maternité car on a
bien compris que votre minimum
contributif à 1200 euros brut leur
passera sous le nez aux femmes puisqu'il
est conditionné à des carrières
complètes qu'elles n'ont pas on est
aussi assez intelligent voyez-vous pour
voir que notre trimestre à qui lors de
la naissance de nos enfants partiront en
fumée avec le report de l'âge légal bref
Elisabeth borne ment quand elle dit que
les femmes seront les grandes gagnantes
vous venez de mentir de nouveau en
disant que cette réforme avantage les
femmes en vérité monsieur le ministre la
vérité c'est qu'avec votre réforme tout
le monde est perdant et que les femmes
sont les grandes perdantes alors dans un
timide élan de sincérité votre collègue
le ministre Riester l'a reconnu les
femmes sont un peu pénalisées par le
report de l'âge légal alors pour
répondre à la litote par la litote je
vous dis qu'elles sont un peu
déterminées à ne pas laisser passer
cette réforme injuste elle se met en
grève quoi qu'il leur en coûte et elle
descend disparu bien décidé à vous faire
reculer et je crois que vous feriez
mieux de les entendre car l'histoire le
montre quand les femmes s'en mêlent le
pouvoir tremble
monsieur le ministre je vous laisse la
parole
la députée je ne doute de l'intelligence
de personnes par définition et c'est
même principe que j'ai dans la vie
politique je pense que les élus sont
intelligents je pense que les électeurs
sont intelligents et je ne crois ni aux
efforts pédagogiques mais uniquement aux
efforts d'explications et de conviction
quand on arrive à avoir les arguments
qu'il faut la deuxième chose c'est que
si je peux partager cela avec vous je ne
vous autorise pas très clairement à dire
que je mens
les éléments que j'ai avancés sont des
éléments qui sont dans l'étude d'impact
et qui montrent des effets de la réforme
tels que ils ont été imaginées pensées
et prévu donc vous avez le droit d'être
un désaccord avec moi mais je ne vous
autorise pas à me prêter de menteur
je vous dis que vous avez le droit
d'être en accord avec moi mais que vous
n'avez pas le droit de nous traiter de
menteur tout le monde va travailler plus
les femmes comme les hommes mais le
graphique de la page 56 le montre il y a
le maintien d'un âge effectif de départ
à la retraite qui sera inférieur pour
les femmes vous dites le minimum pardon
madame mais je crois vous avoir écouté
jusqu'à la fin de votre propos même pour
les parties les moins agréables
la dite n'est pas l'un des sens de
parler de minimum contributifs à 1200
euros mais ce qui est indécent ça serait
de maintenir le niveau des pensions là
où il est peut-être que vous considérez
que c'est insuffisant peut-être que vous
considérez que ça ne compte pas moi je
considère que lorsqu'on améliore on
améliore de 100 euros des pensions qui
sont à 1050 1060 euros aujourd'hui ça
compte et ça compte pour ceux qui vont
pouvoir ainsi en bénéficier et qu'il y a
200 000 retraités par an sur les 800 000
départs qui vont bénéficier d'une
pension meilleure jusqu'à 100 euros par
l'implication de la réforme plutôt que
par sa non application puis enfin un
dernier mais pour dire que j'ai et vous
montrer que j'ai écouté la totalité de
votre question jusqu'à 53 54 secondes
j'étais d'accord avec tout peut-être pas
à la pancarte parce que je n'aurais pas
écrit comme ça mais j'étais d'accord
avec tout sur le fait qu'il y a des
inégalités professionnelles le fait que
les femmes aujourd'hui sont à la
retraite victimes d'inégalités qui sont
la conséquence d'inégalités tout au long
de la vie et je pense que
au-delà du texte et au-delà du débat et
au-delà du désaccord que nous avons sur
la réforme que nous proposons ce
chantier là et je l'ai dit je le répète
reste prioritaire
merci monsieur le ministre pour les
républicains Frédéric meunier merci
madame la Présidente sur le ministre la
droite républicaine a toujours assumé de
réformer les retraites que ce soit
Jacques Chirac à Nicolas Sarkozy pour
sauver notre système par répartition le
système de retraite est structurément
déficitaire en raison de l'inversion
entre autres du rapport démographique
alors qu'on comptait trois cotisants
pour un retraité en 1970 de cotisants
pour un retraité en 2000 il n'y a plus
que 1,7 cotisant aujourd'hui nous sommes
donc convaincus qu'il faut une réforme
de retraite toutefois dans un pays
fracturé avec une situation sociale
explosive une telle réforme doit être
acceptable pour la population ainsi nous
espérons que le débat parlementaire même
si c'est un vœu pieux permettra
d'améliorer la situation des femmes
monsieur le ministre dans les faits les
carrières des femmes sont plus courtes
40% ont une carrière coûte courte contre
32% pour les hommes parce que ce sont
les femmes qui arrêtent ou limitent leur
activité pour élever les enfants ou
s'occuper des personnes dépendantes
alors quatre points nous avons déposé un
amendement qui vise à permettre aux
femmes de partir un trimestre plutôt que
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite
cette situation est particulièrement
importante pour les femmes les femmes
ayant commencé à travailler très jeune
cet amendement a-t-il une chance
d'aboutir
nous avons pu constater qu'il n'y a pas
de prise en compte de la pénibilité pour
les femmes en fait les critères de
pénibilité sont le bruit le travail de
nuit le travail en équipe le travail
répétitif les activités etc etc et ça ne
concerne en réalité en majorité 75% des
femmes
on a pu constater que 1/4 des
aides-soignantes
donne les chiffres pour répartir plus
tôt c'est-à-dire 62 ans alors
qu'aujourd'hui elles peuvent toutes
partir à 57 ans
enfin il faudrait avoir 64 ans pour
bénéficier d'une carrière complète alors
que 40% des femmes n'ont pas de carrière
complète
ça c'est ce qu'on comprenne pas
aujourd'hui les femmes et pour finir
nous n'avons pas encore parlé mais la
pension de réversion pensez-vous qu'il
serait possible pour les veuves PACS de
pouvoir bénéficier d'une pension de
réversion je vous remercie
monsieur
le premier point de votre intervention
et la question de créer finalement une
carrière longue peut-être j'aurais
carrément spécifique femme nous ne
sommes pas sur cette orientation là avec
des modèles et des réponses que nous
étions d'apporter d'améliorer sur des
questions de carrière longue qui sont
des réponses qui
s'appliqueront en tout cas qui
s'adresseront à tous les assurés hommes
et femmes nous regardons par contre
comment la prise en compte des
trimestres que je qualifiais tout à
l'heure à VPS mais aussi des trimestres
congés parentaux peuvent faciliter cet
accès à la durée de cotisation requise y
compris dans le cadre de départ anticipé
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose nous regardons aussi et nous avons
cette attention sur la situation des
assurés et les femmes sont plus
nombreuses dans cette situation que les
hommes à approcher et même à franchir la
d'ouverture des droits sans avoir une
carrière complète et vous l'avez dit
souvent les assurés qui n'ont pas une
carrière complète qui n'ont pas la durée
de cotisation exigée sont des femmes
doivent aller plus loin
le 62 ou 64 ans ne change pas grand
chose d'une certaine manière à cette
situation là puisque très souvent le
fait de devoir aller plus loin les amène
au-delà de 64 ans et c'est lié à cette
inégalité de carrière que j'ai déjà
évoqué c'est pour cette raison par
contre que nous avons fait le choix que
j'ai déjà évoqué de maintenir l'âge de
la décote pour ne pas repousser cette
horizon de suppression de décote par
rapport à un âge de départ à la retraite
sur le troisième point qui est la
question des aides-soignants je veux
dire que le quart vous avez évoqué je ne
l'ai pas en tête donc je reviendrai plus
précisément par contre sur la question
des aidons c'est et les aidants mais on
sait que c'est une profession très
majoritairement féminine on a un très
gros chantier d'harmonisation de droit à
faire aujourd'hui si vous êtes
aide-soignant à l'hôpital public et donc
titulaire de la fonction publique
hospitalière vous êtes considéré comme
catégorie active et vous pouvez partir
avec 5 ans d'avance sur l'âge légal de
départ
si vous êtes aide-soignant dans le même
hôpital mais comme contractuel vous
n'avez pas droit à ce départ anticiper
puisque seuls les titulaires sont
catégories actives si vous êtes soyons
dans le secteur privé vous avez le droit
en tout cas vous pouvez être éligible au
compte professionnel de prévention
l'abaissement des seuils de des
d'obtention des points nous allons que
nous proposons dans la loi va faciliter
l'accès de cette profession d'être
soignants à des points de paix qui
peuvent être convertis soin des parents
dissipés sont quand j'ai de reconversion
et la prise en compte de notre manière
notamment des critères ergonomiques mais
pas dans le cadre du C2P autour de des
postures pénibles du port de charge et
des vibrations notamment pour les deux
premiers critères permettra aussi les
accompagner puis enfin il y a une
troisième situation vous pouvez être
aide-soignant dans la fonction publique
territoriale principalement dans des
EHPAD gérer en régie direct par des CIS
des CCAS et là il n'y a ni compte
personnel de professionnels de
prévention parce qu'il n'est pas ouvert
aux agents publics ni catégorie actif
parce que ça n'existe pas pour ce cadre
d'emploi dans la fonction publique
territoriale si vous ajoutez à la
situation des infirmiers qui est
strictement la même à l'exception de
l'afph ou en fonction de la date de
recrutement vous êtes A ou B donc vous
êtes actif ou sédentaire il y a
maquiller une égalité et un énorme frein
à la mobilité entre ces différents
employeurs dans mes métiers finalement
dans le cadre du fond de prévention pour
les métiers des soignants que François
brun ne va porter qui apparaît dans le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale rectif ça fait partie
des choses sur lesquelles nous devons
trouver les bons outils peut-être
conventionnels pour rétablir cette
égalité entre des hommes et les femmes
et très souvent des femmes qui existent
le même métier mais avec des droites
tout à fait différents
merci monsieur le ministre pour les
écologistes Marie-Charlotte Garin
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre
1145 euros par mois c'est la pension
moyenne de retraite en France pour les
femmes contre 1924 euros pour les hommes
10,4% c'est le taux de pauvreté des
femmes retraitées il est sensiblement
plus élevé que celui des hommes et
c'était car attendre à se creuser depuis
2012 enfin les femmes partent un peu
plus tard à la retraite que les hommes à
la retraite je crois que vous voyez où
je veux en venir c'est que les
inégalités de retraite sont le miroir
des inégalités entre les femmes et les
hommes tout au long de leur vie et
parfois même c'est un miroir grossissant
vous nous dites que l'égalité fameux
vous préoccupe et je l'entends mais
c'est bien la difficulté avec les droits
des femmes c'est qu'au-delà des bonnes
intentions il nous faut des moyens et
des mesures concrètes vous parliez du
chantier de l'égalité famome moi je fais
partie de celle qui en ont marre de
regarder les échafaudages et qui
espèrent voir l'inauguration de leur
vivant que proposez-vous pour remédier
aux inégalités parce qu'aujourd'hui il y
a rien pour remédier aux inégalités
professionnelles malgré la loi de 2006
qui n'est toujours pas appliqué et
aucune sanction vu pour les entreprises
qui ne respectent pas rien pour le taux
d'emploi des femmes je rappelle que la
France est 25e sur les 38 pays de l'OCDE
en la matière et pourtant pourtant s'il
était relevé au même niveau que celui
des hommes ce serait dix milliards de
cotisations supplémentaires pour nos
retraites rien contre l'abus de temps
partiel de certaines entreprises tant
partiels principalement occupé par des
femmes rien pour les inégalités de
salaire alors que si nous arrivions à
salaire égal pour travailler égal entre
les femmes et les hommes nous
augmenterons de 12% les cotisations mais
au-delà de ne rien faire votre réforme
va creuser les inégalités dans un
système qui est déjà défavorable aux
femmes puisque le décalage de l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite de 62 à 64
ans et surtout l'allongement de la durée
des cotisations vont toucher tout le
monde les gens vont compris et ils et
elles sont massivement descendues dans
les rues hier mais cette décision elle
va surtout toucher tous ceux et tout en
fait beaucoup toutes celles qui ont eu
des carrières courtes des carrières
hachées des temps partiels et c'est
aussi simple que cela ne nous y opposons
et je vous le dis avec une certaine
gravité et je me fais l'association des
l'écho des associations féministes qui
vraiment ont le sentiment que vous
instrumentalisez les droits des femmes
pour justifier une réforme d'austérité
budgétaire donc vous ne pouvez pas vous
entêter à présenter cette réforme comme
bénéfique pour les femmes alors même que
ça n'est pas le cas je vous épargne la
sortie d'un autre membre du gouvernement
dont je salue le NT mais au-delà de la
question de l'impact désastreux sur les
femmes de cette réforme je vous demande
de bien penser à l'impact que tout cela
a sur la vie démocratique de notre pays
et sur la confiance qu'on les citoyens
en leurs élus et en leur parole
politique je vous remercie
merci Monsieur le Ministre merci Madame
la député si je suis rapide dans la
réponse parce qu'en fait déjà donné un
certain élément vous avez compris que je
ne partage pas votre sentiment en tout
cas votre affirmation sur l'aggravation
d'une égalité je n'y reviens pas je l'ai
évoqué à plusieurs reprises mais vous
avez aussi compris que nous partageons
je crois tous ici c'est gentil pour
l'égalité professionnelle femme je
trouve à vrai dire un peu sévère quand
vous dites il n'y a rien pour tel point
à tel point à tel point il y a d'autres
lois que celle de 2006 qui ont été
adoptés il y a l'index que j'ai évoqué
qui se mette en place avec des sanctions
à la clé pour cette index peut-être que
nous pouvons aller plus loin évidemment
et quand vous dites que vous en avez
marre de voir des échafaudages et que
vous aimeriez inaugurer la fin du
chantier moi aussi et si je suis
totalement direct et honnête dans ma
réponse j'aimerais que ce soit le cas
j'aimerais que ce soit le plus rapide
mais je CRA malgré tout et pas seulement
tu fais de disposition législatives au
réglementaire mais parfois de la durée
et du temps que prenne certaines notre
société que ça nécessite et pour vous et
pour moi qu'on est une certaine
longévité en politique mais ce sentiment
le sentiment le partage
ne m'obligez pas à dire que c'est pas le
sommet à court terme madame la député
oui c'est vrai c'est
urgent parce que le déficit est là il
est bien là mais je crois qu'on ne sera
pas d'accord sur ce point et peut-être
que vous conviendrez madame la député
après m'avoir interrompu 9 fois depuis
cette séance que
au dise peut-être je sais pas je ne
voudrais pas minimiser votre effort mais
quand il y avait peut-être avec moi que
le chantier de l'égalité professionnelle
nécessite des mesures qui prennent un
peu plus de temps dans l'application que
des chantiers comme ceux que l'on que
l'on que l'on mène par quand on parle de
du PLFSS mais vraiment sur l'égalité
professionnelle femme je vais le dire je
ne sais combien de fois cette fois-ci
mais mais on a beaucoup à faire et en
plus je suis assez convaincu que ça fait
partie des sujets sur lesquels chacun
peut se retrouver
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie la
parole pour le modem est un Sandrine
jossou merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues on
est ravis de vous recevoir aujourd'hui
au sein de la délégation et vous le
savez pour cause le projet de loi de
financement rectifié actif de la
sécurité sociale est porteur de
nombreuses avancées pour la situation
des femmes comme par exemple la
revalivorisation de 100 euros des
minimas de retraite pour les futurs
retraités et les personnes déjà à la
retraite ainsi 1,8 millions de retraités
bénéficieront de cette mesure de justice
sociale et dans ces 1,8 millions de
retraités 60% sont des femmes
aussi n'oublions pas la meilleure prise
en compte des carrières longues et
interrompues pour s'occuper d'un enfant
ou d'une personne dépendante dans des
plaies à certains nous le savons toutes
et tous se sont en premier lieu des
femmes qui verront demain leur retraite
améliorée le gouvernement auquel vous
appartenez prouve ainsi par des actes
que l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes est bien la grande cause du
quinquennat soyez certains que le groupe
démocrate continuera d'être à vos côtés
pour voter cette réforme pour autant
monsieur le ministre le groupe démocrate
pense qu'il est possible d'aller plus
loin en faveur des femmes notamment en
ce qui concerne la maternité
oui notre système de retraite manque
encore de justice envers les assurés
ayant eu une carrière hachée qui sont
bien souvent des femmes lorsqu'elles ont
eu un ou plusieurs enfants celles-ci
vont devoir travailler jusqu'à 67 ans
pour éviter de liquider leur pension
avec une décote
dites nous monsieur le ministre comment
le système de retraite pourrait-il mieux
soutenir les femmes qui ont eu des
enfants et pensez-vous qu'une politique
de soutien de la natalité soit
importante pour garantir la pérennité de
notre système par répartition et nous
aimerions également savoir si l'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes fera
partie des priorités du prochain projet
de loi sur le travail merci
merci Madame ma collègue monsieur le
ministre
merci Madame présente Madame la député
d'abord pour répondre à la dernière
question oui ça serait un contresens que
de porter un projet de loi sur plein
d'emploi elle travaille l'accès à la
formation professionnelle sans utiliser
ce véhicule pour porter des dispositions
qui permettent d'améliorer l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes ça c'est
la première chose la deuxième chose
concernant la prise en compte ou en tout
cas la manière de lutter contre les
effets des cari rachides cela renvoie au
dispositions que j'ai évoquée la prison
compte des trimestres de congé parentaux
pour les éligibilité au minimum de
pension pour les ligibilité
au système de calcul des
léger vidéo carrière longue excusez-moi
pour ce bafouillement et nous avons la
même logique pour les trimestres validé
au titre de l'assurance vieilles des
aidons avec cette volonté d'aller un peu
plus avant et d'accompagner ceux qui
aident qui sont dans l'immense majorité
des cas des femmes il y a une autre
mesure que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure je
sais votre groupe y être attaché c'est
cette question de la majoration de 10% à
partir du troisième enfant que nous
souhaitons harmoniser faut faire en
sorte qu'il y ait un maximum de
d'assurer qui puisse avoir droit à cela
je fais une association d'idées parce
que j'ai vu que Madame meunier me disait
que je n'ai pas répondu intégralement et
votre question m'a permis de voir ce à
quoi je n'ai pas répondu sur les
questions de droit familiaux c'est la
question des pensions de reversion nous
n'avons pas ouvert dans le texte tel que
nous vous le présentons dans pas inscrit
disposition sur les pensions de
reversion il y avait dans la réforme
précédente un objectif à 70% qui est se
marier très bien avec la mise en place
d'un système universel dans le cas d'un
système qui reste un système par régime
cet accès harmonisé à la pension de
réversion n'est pas aussi simple que
cela mais nous devons je crois ça relève
aussi de ce chantier sur les droits
familiaux faire en sorte d'ici Le Pen
FSS pour 2024 qu'il y a une
harmonisation en matière de droit
aujourd'hui nous allons très régime de
pensions de réversion et 13 règles
différentes
certaines règles sont assujetti à des
conditions de ressources et d'autres pas
du tout ce qui est une inégalité assez
fondamentale se posera aussi la question
et c'est là que Madame Monier m'avait
interrogé de l'éligibilité à la pension
de réversion de partenaires PACS je ne
vous cache pas mais là c'est l'ancien
ministre budget qui réagit c'est
extrêmement cher d'une part et par
ailleurs ça renvoie mais je le dis sans
le trancher parce que je pense que c'est
un débat qui renvoie aussi à
l'organisation même de la société et à
la manière dont on conçoit l'union entre
deux
êtres et à la nature de cette union
juridique ça envoie un autre débat qui
est dans le cadre du mariage
aujourd'hui ouvert à tous les couples il
y a un engagement d'assistance mutuelle
de solidarité
au-delà d'autres engagements qui sont
rappelés par le Code civil et cette
engagement de solidarité d'assistance
mutuelle qui apparaît dans le mariage
dans les articles du Code civil
rappelait à l'occasion de la cérémonie
de mariage n'apparaît pas
sur le PACS et certains juristes je dis
bien comme ça comme ça parce que je ne
veux pas trancher le débat considère
finalement la pension de réversion et la
traduction post mortem pardon de le dire
comme ça de cet engagement d'assistance
et de solidarité mutuelle qui n'existe
pas dans le pack et qui n'aurait pas
lieu à exister de manière post mortem et
d'aucun considère aussi que désormais
dans un sixième juridique où le PACS est
accessible à tous les couples et où le
mariage est accessible à tous les
couples cette possibilité d'avoir deux
régimes différenciés s'explique par
cette absence d'assistance d'engagement
et assistance mutuel mais là aussi le
débat gagnera je pense à être monnaie
je vous remercie la parole pour le
groupe horizon à Anne-Cécile violon
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues monsieur le
ministre tout d'abord je tiens à vous
remercier pour les premières avancées
prises en compte des spécificités des
carrières des femmes les axes de progrès
dans cette nécessaire réforme de
retraite même si nous sommes toutes
d'accord et impatientes elles sont
largement perfectibles je crois en la
sincérité de votre préoccupation et je
salue vos efforts de pédagogie le 23
janvier dernier le 11 conseils à
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
publiait son rapport annuel consacré à
un état des lieux actuels sur le sexisme
en France ce rapport fut notamment état
d'une reconnaissance massive de
l'inégalité entre les hommes et les
femmes dans toutes les sphères de la
société vous l'avez évoqué le constat
est particulièrement alarmant dans le
monde du travail puisque seulement 20%
de la population estime que les femmes
et les hommes y sont égaux en pratique
de plus nous notons que les femmes sont
largement sur représentées dans les
métiers précaires et les métiers du soir
aux conditions de travail dégradées et
aux horaires atypiques
ces inégalités se répercutent ensuite
sur les pensions de retraite ainsi le
texte prochainement débattu pourrait
être une belle occasion de corriger ces
inégalités face à l'emploi face aux
indemnités retraite suite à votre
introduction de ce jour je crois
comprendre que vous souhaitez en
profiter pour favoriser l'emploi des
femmes seniors particulièrement
difficultés et notamment arerter sur la
situation de ces femmes dans le sens de
l'amendement déposé par notre collègue
madame panonacle je pense que vous avez
répondu je me permets d'ouvrir d'une
manière plus générale et d'autre
attention sur la problématique des
femmes travaillant dans le milieu
médical et paramédical au-delà des
problématiques de pénibilité posturale
évoquée par ma collègue madame meunier
les dernières données sanitaires sont
formelles ces soignantes de par leur
surexposition à des composés nocifs
volatils de la part de la rotation des
horaires jour nuit son sujet à une forte
prévalence de pathologies cancéreuses
notamment le cancer du sein de grossesse
pathologiques de problématique
addictives ou despressive évidemment
tout cela va impacter leur qualité de
vie en général leur santé leur carrière
évidemment leur retraite comment prendre
en compte ces risques spécifiques des
femmes soignantes dans un développement
d'axes majeurs de politique publique je
vous remercie monsieur ministre merci
Monsieur ministre
sur le premier point je crois avoir
répondu et je pense que nous aurons
l'occasion d'avancer le projet de Loi
sur l'emploi le travail la formation je
le dis comme ça parce que son titre
exact n'est pas encore arrêté sera
présenté au Parlement avant l'été donc
permettra d'avancer assez rapidement sur
ces mesures là et je serai dans ce cadre
là preneur de toutes les propositions
permettant de progresser sur ce sujet
sur la problématique ou la situation
particulière des femmes soignantes je
dois bien avouer ne pas savoir répondre
comme cela d'abord parce que ce sont des
spécialités qui sont assez loin des
compétences qui sont les miennes et je
ne peux que renvoyer au chantier aux
outils puisque chantier que ce projet de
loi donne à François Brown mon collègue
en charge de la santé notamment avec la
création d'un fond de prévention
d'accompagnement des métiers du soin
celui qui sont pénibilité d'attractivité
de conciliation vie professionnelle
personnelle et que nous souhaitons doter
de 100 millions d'euros par an ce qui
est une somme qui peut paraître comme ça
anecdotique dans une période où on parle
souvent de sommes très importantes mais
qui est considérable par rapport à ce
qui se fait en matière d'accompagnement
de ces métiers là c'est dans ce cadre-là
qu'on prend de suite à toutes les
mesures que vous évoqueriez et aux
attentes au sujet sur lesquels vous avez
appelé mon attention
je vous remercie pour le groupe GTR
madame Karine Lebon merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre
pardonnez-moi en retard j'étais retenue
dans l'hémicycle merci de me permettre
de poser ma question le ministre des
Relations avec le Parlement la lui-même
dit cette réforme va impacter
particulièrement les femmes et je
pourrais rajouter particulièrement les
femmes ultramarines mon département la
Réunion est en effet le département de
France or Mayotte où les pensions de
retraite sont les plus faibles les
seniors à la Réunion sont
particulièrement nombreux à dépendre du
minimum vieillesse 17% contre 4% en
hexagone de plus les familles
monoparentales sont nombreuses dans les
outre-mer ce sont souvent des familles
pauvres et dans la plupart des cas ces
familles monoparentales sont tenues par
des femmes elles n'ont pas d'autre choix
elles ne peuvent pas
faire autrement que de prendre des temps
partiels pour s'occuper de l'éducation
de leurs enfants et c'est là aura un
impact au moment de la retraite monsieur
le ministre que prévoit le gouvernement
pour la situation particulière des
femmes ultramarines le SMIC chez nous
n'a été aligné qu'en 1996 certains
métiers sont entrés tardivement dans le
régime de cotisation nous devons avoir
une réflexion particulière à ce sujet la
réforme de l'assurance chômage ne
s'applique pas chez nous pouvons-nous en
faire de même pour les retraites et pour
conclure je souhaiterais aborder un
point qui m'a été communiqué par
l'association EVA pour la vie il est
vrai que les enfants peuvent apporter
jusqu'à 8 trimestres au maire de famille
oui mais si les maires travaillent dans
le public il faut que l'enfant survive
au-delà de l'âge de 9 ans 4 ans dans le
privé c'est la double peine quand on a
un enfant qui meurt dans le cancer quand
on est une mère en deuillée alors bien
sûr se rattrapage de trimestres ne
ramènera pas leur enfant mais si on peut
éviter à ces mères d'être doublement
puni ce serait un premier pas vers
l'empathie et la compassion je vous
remercie
monsieur le ministre
sur le point que vous évoquez
je découvre avec vous c'est à dire que
je sais la différence de traitement
entre les femmes assurées du régime
public les femmes assuré du régime
général il y a 4 mois et deux mois et
c'est déjà une forme d'inégalité mais
sur la question que vous évoquez par
rapport à un éventuels dans son je
découvre avec vous et si vous voulez
bien on va le on va le vérifier on va le
regarder enfin je crois sur parole mais
je découvre donc je ne sais pas vous
dire plus que ça on va on va regarder
cela et si vous le voulez bien on
revient vers vous
on va regarder tout cela et n'hésitez
pas si enfin je ne veux pas je ne veux
pas être accusé de vouloir influencer le
travail des parlementaires mais si vous
souhaitez qu'on regarde l'amendement
avant pour voir comment on peut avancer
n'hésitez surtout pas sur la question
des retraites outre-mer j'ai eu
l'occasion de répondre à des questions
d'actualité à l'exception de Mayotte qui
est dans une situation très particulière
la réforme va s'appliquer outre-mer de
manière classique mais dans une
situation qui ne l'est pas qu'il n'est
pas parce que vous l'avez dit beaucoup
des assurés ont des carrières qui sont
soit difficiles à reconstituer soit
appuyer sur des niveaux de semis qui
n'avaient pas été alignés parfois encore
dans des périodes de convergence et nous
savons qu'il y a une situation
aujourd'hui effective que l'on constate
qui fait que le l'âge de départ effectif
à la retraite outre-mer et déjà très
significatif très significativement
supérieur pour les raisons que vous avez
évoqué à celui que nous constatons
métropole à la Réunion par exemple c'est
64,3 ans alors qu'en métropole on est à
62 ans et deux mois ou 63 ou 62 ans
trois mois en âge effectif pardonnez-moi
63 ans et de moi en âge effectif de
départ il y a une explication qui est
négative c'est la faiblesse du niveau de
cotisation la faiblesse des revenus et
des carrières plus hachées qu'en
métropole qui explique que les assurés
plus loin en termes d'âge avant de faire
valoir leur droit il y a une conséquence
et je bosse pas dire positive c'est
qu'une conséquence qui est que dans un
système dans une réforme tel que nous la
portons avec un relèvement de l'âge
légal de deux ans progressivement même
après le relèvement cela ne sera pas
mordant d'une certaine manière pour des
assurer donc là j'effectif déjà
supérieur à ce que sera le nouvel âge
légal mais il y a des travaux à mener
d'amélioration indépendant même de la
réforme je pense par exemple dans des
territoires comme celui de la Réunion et
j'ai peur de vous dire une bêtise je
crois que c'est la Guadeloupe j'hésite
toujours entre la Guadeloupe et la
Martinique sur ce sujet là il a par
exemple une inégalité qui subsiste pour
les salariés du secteur agricole du
secteur agricole puisque le régime agir
Carco complémentaire obligatoire ne
s'applique pas aux salariés du régime du
secteur agricole à la Réunion et en
Guadeloupe il me semble ça relève des
partenaires sociaux mais indépendamment
même de la réforme ça fait partie des
sujets sur lesquels il y a des éléments
de rétablissement d'égalité d'équité à
mettre en place
merci monsieur le ministre à la parole
est à Mireille clapot merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre merci
d'être ici je suis convaincu de votre
sincérité sur la recherche de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes en
matière travail je salue d'ailleurs ici
les avancées les points positifs de la
réforme pour les femmes et ma
satisfaction du vote en commission de
l'amendement de ma collègue qui inclut
une distinction par sexe dans l'index
seniors toutefois ayant travaillé en
circonscription sur l'emploi des seniors
en général je voudrais vous interroger
sur la spécificité la spécificité de
l'emploi des femmes seniors et encore
lire sur leur futur retraite première
situation c'est celle des femmes qui ont
dû quitter leur emploi pendant plusieurs
années pour s'occuper de leurs proches
parce que la culture française les
pousse à s'arrêter à s'occuper de leurs
enfants elle se retrouve sur le marché
du travail quelques années plus tard
elles ont aujourd'hui de grandes
difficultés à décrocher des entretiens
et à retrouver le monde professionnel
alors vous me direz plus que les hommes
et bien oui parce que souvent le vivant
un isolement social et son éloignées des
codes de l'entreprise
elles ont perdu confiance en elles j'ai
donc porté un amendement dans le cadre
du plfssr pour que le service public de
l'emploi propose un accompagnement
spécifique au seniors une sorte de
mission locale pour les seniors est-ce
que c'est envisageable donc pour les
femmes
deuxième situation c'est les femmes qui
sont partis dans le cadre d'accord avec
leur entreprise qui sont au chômage qui
auraient dû normalement faire la
jonction avec les retraites or
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
va les placer dans une situation
précaire parce que les femmes sont plus
souvent incitées que les hommes à quitté
l'entreprise par un plan de départ
volontaire elles ont aussi moins de
patrimoine que les hommes voire le livre
de Céline Bessières et Sybille golak le
jean du capital ils ont moins de
patrimoine moins d'économie donc elles
sont plus en difficulté d'où cette
question et puis je ne sais pas si j'ai
encore quelques secondes il y a la
question de la formation formation
situation de travail pour améliorer
l'employabilité des femmes comment
est-ce qu'on peut vérifier que ces
modalités de formation sont bien
proposées à ce public spécifique je vous
remercie merci monsieur le ministre
l'essentiel de la réponse que donne la
député va tenir pour la question
des de l'implication des entreprises et
du service de l'emploi en matière
d'emploi des femmes et particulièrement
des femmes seniors dans le fait qu'on
nous puissions et c'est le sens vraiment
qui a reçu favorable de la commission
hier je crois ou avant-hier d'avoir des
mesures qui sont genre pour ce qui
concerne l'index au Seigneur mais une
fois que j'ai dit cela sur la capacité à
avoir une mesure jeanrée de cet accès du
maintien de l'emploi des seniors la
réponse tient aussi dans des mesures
pour l'emploi des seigneurs qui soient
les plus générales et les plus efficaces
possibles la question de la formation
pas seulement pour les femmes pour tous
les seigneurs aujourd'hui nous savons
que les salariés qui ont plus de 50 ans
ont un accès à la formation continue qui
est à peu près égale à la moitié de
l'accès à la formation continue de
salarié de moins de 50 ans et ça tient
la fois aux entreprises qui investissent
moins en matière de formation pour leur
salarié les plus âgés mais parfois aussi
aux sentiments par les salariés pour les
salariés que l'effort de formation
deviendrait moins évident moins efficace
moins utile après après quand on est
donc c'est au-delà des mesures que nous
allons prendre un changement extrêmement
important de culture managériale et de
culture d'entreprise qu'il nous faut
pour que l'emploi des sénates soit plus
considéré comme un franc il y a un autre
aspect que je n'ai pas évoqué
aujourd'hui mais qui répond en partie à
la problématique et la vote pour les
femmes comme pour les hommes mais
peut-être parce qu'on sait que les
carrerachers sont plus nombreuses pour
les femmes que pour les hommes qu'il y a
un effet plus massif pour les femmes que
pour les hommes c'est la question de la
retraite progressive le fait de
permettre d'être faciliter l'accès
d'accès à la retraite progressive dans
le privé et de l'ouvrir d'un secteur
public est aussi un moyen d'accompagner
les fins de carrière et de rendre de
permettre finalement de décélérer de
lever le pied en terme de charge
professionnelle sans renoncer à à
cotiser et donc à valider et cotiser des
trimestres de manière à pouvoir aller
jusqu'à une carrière complète mais dans
une situation où l'effort en termes de
travail et moindre et donc d'éviter la
décote qui peut parfois arriver
de capacité à aller jusqu'au bout de
cette carrière professionnelle
je vous remercie pour elle et Lise le
boucher
merci
Monsieur le Ministre merci de votre
présence alors comme la reconnue votre
collègue monsieur Riester c'est très
fort à particulièrement impacter les
femmes alors n'avions pas besoin de lui
pour le comprendre les femmes ont bien
compris comme le reste de la population
elle ne veut pas perdre 2 ans de leur
vie alors je vais pas reprendre ce que
c'était beaucoup d'îles et le fait que
les inégalités de notre système de
retraite sont corrélie finalement aux
inégalités sur le marché sur le marché
de l'emploi il a déjà été évoqué
certaines pistes pistes de travail
et en effet je pense qu'au-delà de cette
réforme il est
urgent il c'est possible qu'on veut dans
l'urgence d'avoir un plan massif pour
attraper notre retard par rapport au
marché de l'emploi quelques pistes de
travail ont déjà été soulignés l'égalité
salariale mais aussi on peut penser à
l'engagement du congé paternité la
création d'un vrai service public de la
petite enfance
la contribution obligatoire des
employeurs qui imposait tantiel et aussi
une piste importante alors j'ai pas été
forcément très à l'écoute mais j'ai pas
l'impression que vous ayez beaucoup
répondu sur les critères de pénibilité
sur les métiers féminins ou donc ça a
été dit les critères de pénibilité on si
un regard quand même assez sexiste parce
qu'il concerne essentiellement des
métiers masculins où en effet les ports
de charge
dans un secteur alors que dans un autre
secteur plus féminin qui va être le même
n'est pas pris n'est pas prise en compte
et l'enjeu de cette réformes aussi voilà
c'est en 2023 il est temps que les
femmes aussi à leur propre droit et pas
des droits dérivés lui au conjoint on
sort aussi de ce système patriarcal les
femmes sont aujourd'hui pleinement dans
le monde du travail alors faisons
évoluer notre protection sociale
monsieur le ministre merci d'avoir la
député sur différents éléments ce qu'on
a déjà échangé sur le sujet mais
peut-être sur la question de la
pénibilité en deux points trois points
pardon d'abord l'amélioration du C2P que
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
notamment dans ces modes d'amélioration
deux choses qui peuvent profiter qui
vont profiter des métiers qui se
caractérisent par leur féminisation
l'abaissement du seuil du nombre de nuit
à travailler chaque année pour valider
les points et obtenir des points de C2P
s'adresse évidemment et va permettre à
beaucoup plus de métiers du soin de
l'aide à domicile de du secteur
médico-sociaux de valider des points
aussi du C2P et cet abaissement de seuil
est plutôt bénéfique pour les métiers
qui sont féministes de la même manière
nous allons améliorer la prise en compte
de la polyexposition et derrière la
police exposition peut aussi retrouver
un certain nombre de métiers du soin
dans le secteur privé je ne reviens pas
sur ce que je disais tout à l'heure à
propos des aides soignants dans le
public et du fonds de prévention de
François Brown la deuxième chose c'est
que il y a aussi un certain nombre de
métiers qui sont aujourd'hui très
féminins très féminisé pardon je
notamment au secteur de l'aide à
domicile et le fait que nous puissions
n'ont pas réintégrer au C2P mais
travailler à la fin de prévention en
termes de suivi médical renforcé pour
permettre des départs anticipées sur les
critères
ergonomiques et notamment les postures
pénibles le port de charge ça va
permettre d'emmener dans cette aspect de
la pénibilité de la prévention de la
pénibilité les métiers de l'aide à
domicile pardonnez-moi qui se
caractérise par des manipulations par du
port du charges et la prise en compte de
personnes et puis il y a un aspect que
je n'ai pas évoqué tout à l'heure que
j'ai évoqué mais qui renvoie aussi la
question de la pénibilité dans le
secteur public c'est le fait de
faciliter la prise en compte quel
l'accès au bénéfice
de la Carette des catégories actives
notamment pour les aides soignants
lorsque j'ai évoqué ça tout à l'heure je
l'ai fait très rapidement et
pardonnez-moi ce que je suis un peu
confus et fatigué mais je vous l'avais
d'autant moins entendu que je l'ai fait
au Sénat donc
et donc vous inquiétez pas c'est juste
une journée mais merci attention je
compte sur vous mais j'ai dit au Sénat
sur la question de laquelle des
catégories actives dans la fonction
publique on va faire plusieurs choses
notamment permettre la portabilité ce
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui a fonctionnaire
qui travaille dans une catégorie active
et qui fait par exemple c'est un métier
très masculin 15 ans comme surveillant
de prison 15 ans comme policier on lui
dit qu'il a droit à rien parce qu'il
faut faire 17 ans dans un corps et
uniquement un corps ou 27 ans donc la
portabilité va permettre de reconnaître
des droits au départ anticipés pour ceux
qui se excellent qui auront accumulé des
années d'active dans différents corps
considérés comme actifs c'est la
première chose mais il y a deux choses
qui sont importantes je crois pour un
métier très féminin qui est celui des
aides seulement c'est la suppression de
la clause d'achèvement c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui pour bénéficier du départ
anticipé il faut vous le montrer qu'au
moment où vous quittez votre poste pour
partir à la retraite vous êtes dans le
corps considéré comme actif le fait
d'autoriser le fait de l'occuper un
poste considéré comme sédentaire à la
fin de votre carrière sera possible par
la suppression de la cloche d'achèvement
ce qui est une forme d'accompagnement
pour permettre l'accès des fonctions
peut-être plus administratives pour
celles et ceux qui le peuvent et la
deuxième chose c'est la prise en compte
de
la durée de travail dans une catégorie
active comme contractuelle aujourd'hui
je reprends l'exemple des aides
soignants
si vous êtes contractuel dans un hôpital
public pendant 10 ans et que vous êtes
ensuite titularisé comme être seulement
votre décompte d'année en catégorie
actif pour avoir droit à des parents
anticipé comment en ce moment la
titularisation le fait d'intégrer le
fait d'intégrer les années fêtes comme
contractuel c'est parfois 10 parfois 2
smartphone 3 permettra aussi de
renforcer à cet aspect là
je vous remercie la parole est à Amélia
la graphie
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues monsieur le
ministre je tiens tout d'abord à vous
remercier chaleureusement d'être présent
durant ce temps politique partiellement
chargé et important ma question porte
sur l'engagement associatif si le don
est une association fait l'objet d'une
exonération d'impôts rien n'est fait en
revanche pour ceux qui contribuent à son
bon fonctionnement or le bénévolat est
un moteur central de notre solidarité il
contribue même à la création de richesse
de notre pays l'engagement de nos
compatriotes représente ainsi 3% du PIB
de la France en 2022 parmi nos
concitoyens bénévoles les femmes
occupent une place centrale majoritaire
majoritairement présente dans les
secteurs associatifs de l'éduc dans
l'éducation pardon la culture et
l'humanitaire elles sont au coeur de
notre tissu associatif dans tous nos
territoires et même quand elles mettent
leur carrière entre parenthèses pour
suivre leur conjoint en expatriation
nous retrouvons nos compatriotes au sein
de l'association française comme les
accueils les entraides
le feu ou la DFE au travers desquels
elle contribue à la vie de la communauté
et au rayonnement de la France à
l'étranger face à ce constat il n'est
pas illégitime de se poser la question
d'une meilleure prise en compte des
périodes de bénévolat dans le calcul des
droits à la retraite dès lors que cet
engagement répond à l'activité régulière
et reconnue plusieurs propositions de
loi ont été déposées en ce sens ces
dernières années certains collègues
députés défendront les amendements
similaires dans le cadre de cette
réforme au-delà d'une forme de
reconnaissance une telle perspective
pourrait permettre plus spécifiquement
aux femmes de compenser les inégalités
de carrière et donc de retrait dont
elles font l'objet je souhaiterais donc
savoir avoir votre analyse et votre
point de vue sur ce type d'évolution
merci Monsieur le Ministre merci madame
la présidente
des bénévoles nous n'avons pas inscrit
vous l'avez vu dans le projet de loi de
validation trimestre titre du bénévolat
parce que le sujet est certes important
et je partage ce que vous avez dit sur
sur l'importance de cette engagement
mais il est extrêmement complexe à
valider ou à valoriser sous forme de
trimestre d'abord parce que très souvent
pas tout le temps on met très souvent le
bénévolat peut-être réalisé par des
hommes et des femmes qui sont en
activité qui ont un emploi et qui par
ailleurs cotise valide un certain nombre
de trimestres et j'écarte même le
bénévolat réalisé plutôt par des
retraités là c'est un cas encore
différent et surtout la mesure du
bénévolat n'existe pas aujourd'hui on a
tous plein d'exemples en tête on peut
tous témoigner de telle ou telle
association et d'engagement de tel ou
tel personne sur des postes de
responsabilité bénévoles mais nous ne
savons pas véritablement mesurer
autrement que de manière déclarative et
la question qui nous faudra qu'il nous
faudra répondre mais ça ne sera pas dans
le cas de ce texte ça pourra faire
l'objet de travaux ultérieurs ils sont
demandés et nous
serons c'est comment est-ce qu'on fait
pour déterminer le niveau d'intensité de
temps consacré une activité bénévole
pour justifier d'une prise en compte ou
d'une majoration d'une modification de
pension ou durée de cotisation il y a
des bénévoles qui font qui vont
consacrer un temps incroyable
sur des activités qui sont difficiles à
quantifier ou à mesurer mais qui me
relève d'un contact humain absolument
nécessaire d'autres qui vont consacrer
un temps incroyable sur des questions de
gestion et puis d'autres et ça n'enlève
rien les qualités de cet engagement qui
vont se consacrer quelques heures de
loin loin pour participer à
l'organisation d'événements tout ne peut
pas être pris en compte de la même
manière il y a un gros travail de
défrichage à faire pour cela un peu sur
le modèle de ce que nous avons commencé
initié d'ailleurs pour la VAE en matière
de VAE on le fait avec ma ministre nous
travaillons sur cette possibilité de
reconnaître des compétences acquises
dans le cadre de l'exercice de
responsabilité dans le secteur bénévole
merci monsieur le ministre pour
les filles Pascal Martin
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre rappelons une réalité les
femmes travaillent plus que les hommes
45 minutes de plus par jour en Europe
pour être précise sauf que plus de la
moitié de leur travail est réalisée
gratuitement et quand leur travail est
rémunéré il est bien plus mal en moyenne
que celui des hommes résultat les femmes
se retrouvent avec des pensions de
retraite inférieure de 40% en moyenne à
celle des hommes votre réforme loin de
résoudre cette inégalité valaccentuer ça
a été dit par ma collègue et c'est écrit
noir sur blanc de votre étude d'impact
vous qui êtes ministre du Travail
pouvez-vous expliquer aux femmes de ce
pays pourquoi depuis 5 ans et demi
aucune mesure ambitieuse n'a été prise
pour prévenir ces inégalités en amont en
agissant sur l'accès au travail des
femmes et sur les inégalités salariales
améliorer l'accès des femmes à l'emploi
lutter contre les inégalités de salaire
voilà un bien meilleur moyen de financer
notre système de retraite et de réduire
ce déficit que vous craignez tellement
merci monsieur le ministre
merci pardon madame la députée très bref
pour avoir répondu plusieurs fois au
même question je note simplement vous
n'avez pas cité mon collègue ce qui m'a
étonné parce que ça avait été le cas
jusqu'à présent à chaque fois mais c'est
pour ça que je note non plus
sérieusement deux choses des choses à
souligner d'abord il y a des il y a des
actes je n'ai pas dit tout à l'heure en
réponse à certains de certaines de vos
collègues de tous les groupes mais sur
la question de l'égalité professionnelle
femme homme qui se met en place
progressivement et avec un niveau de
sanction et de coercition qui augmente
nous avons quand nous avons c'est
l'administration procéder à 695 mise en
demeure 42 sanctions financières et ces
conformes à la montée en charge que nous
prévoyons mais ça se traduit en acte qui
est plutôt une bonne chose parce que ça
va permettre de pousser à des actions
correctrices qui sont particulièrement
utiles
votre intervention permet d'apporter un
élément pour montrer que nous avons un
système qui a un caractère distributif
même s'il est encore très imparfait en
matière d'égalité ou d'inégalité femme
l'imperfection étant liée au déroulement
de carrière on l'a déjà tous constaté
dit et je crois partager vous avez
évoqué 40 % des cas on est un peu plus
de 30 aujourd'hui mais le chiffre que
vous avez évoqué était juste s'il y a
quelques années non non justement avec
les pensions en version de la 28 je
disais ça justement pour dire que les
droits familiaux et les personnes en
version permettent et c'est heureux de
diminuer un peu l'écart mais nous
progressons petit à petit le 40% que
vous avez évoqué plutôt autour 32 33
aujourd'hui les pensions en version
permettent de le faire baisser mais
l'objectif est comme l'a dit madame la
présidente de la délégation tout à
l'heure c'est que à horizon peut-être
2050 ça peut paraître loin mais c'est 25
ans nous soyons sur un écart 0 ça sera
ça réégalité mais ça passera par
l'égalité preuve par l'égalité tout au
long de la vie
merci monsieur le ministre pour le modem
madame poeto oui merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre bonjour
et merci alors en fait ce n'est pas
tellement au nom de ma famille politique
dans le groupe que j'ai m'exprimer mais
plutôt en tant que membre de la
commission défense et particulièrement
attentive à la situation des femmes de
militaires et je vais citer le Florence
Parly lorsqu'elle était ministre qui
disait les familles sont au cœur de
l'engagement militaire ce sont les
soldats que l'on recrute mais ce sont
des familles qui s'engagent et quand
elle disait ça elle a mis en place toute
un dispositif que nous avons appelé le
plan famille alors permettez-moi juste
de soulever le problème de ces conjointe
de militaires qui
vont bien souvent par le biais du fait
qu'il s'en aille qui s'en va en OPEX
quand ils laissent pas leur vie
malheureusement pour certaines et qui
donc ont un plan j'ai envie de dire
professionnel et familial
donc c'est conjointe de militaires
expriment d'ailleurs plusieurs reprises
plusieurs de difficultés au-delà du
célibat géographique et des tensions
générées par une vie de famille frappée
par l'absence de l'itinérance c'est le
plus souvent le défaut d'une forme de
statut de conjointe qui est pointée du
doigt en compensation à la suggestion
qui est s'impose aux époux et par
conséquent en famille les sujets qui les
préoccupent sont essentiellement accès à
l'emploi après une mutation les
carrières hachées on en a beaucoup parlé
qui est accompagnent leur parcours et
surtout les pensions de retraite à moins
de riz le plan famille a apporté de ce
plan-là de sérieuses évolutions en la
matière mais n'a pas été en capacité à
ce jour d'aborder la question des
pensions de retraite des conjointe en
cause l'architecture du système de
retraite par répartition qui repose sur
les cotisations des actifs comment
pensez-vous que l'on puisse accompagner
les conjointe de militaires qui
souffrent des carrières hachées en
raison de la suggestion qui s'impose
c'est un sujet que j'aborderai lorsque
évidemment le débat viendra dans
l'hémicycle mais je vous remercie madame
la Présidente d'avoir suggéré et obtenu
de du ministre d'être là pour répondre
très directement à nos questions il le
fait comme d'habitude d'une manière très
claire et très disponible merci je
souscris à vos propos monsieur le
ministre merci d'abord pour commencer
mais malheureusement je ne vais pas
pouvoir beaucoup répondre
donc je ne serai pas la hauteur de vos
mots ça va non juste faut que je regarde
parce que je connais pas assez le sujet
la seule chose qui m'est signalé à
l'instant mais je vous le dis comme on
vient de me livrer c'est que notamment
pour les femmes de militaires pour
largement les conjoints militaires en
fait pas seulement les femmes en OPEX il
y a une possibilité d'affiliation
volontaire lorsqu'on est à l'étranger le
dispositif est certainement mal connu
j'en connais moi moi même pas les
concours les contours donc je n'en dis
pas plus mais il faut qu'on puisse
regarder ça mais je préfère ne pas plus
m'avancer je vous dirai des bêtises dans
le cas contraire
merci Monsieur le Ministre même Céline
Calvez
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre nous devons toutes et tous agir
pour lutter contre les inégalités entre
les femmes et les hommes c'est ce que
nous majorité présidentielle nous
employons à faire depuis 2017 à ce titre
la réforme des retraites que vous portez
monsieur le ministre que nous portons
également va dans le bon sens et vous
démonstration en introduction cette
audition ainsi que les graphiques que
vous nous avez distribués en ont
souligner le fondement vous avez su
souligner les conséquences sur les
retraites des grandes inégalités dans la
vie professionnelle mais aussi
personnelle entre femmes et hommes vous
avez aussi celui-ci souligné la façon
dont la place des femmes dans la vie
professionnelle avaient bien évolué
depuis les années 60 nous ne sommes pas
du tout encore dans l'égalité réelle non
mais ne nions pas les évolutions
positives il reste à prendre des mesures
vous en proposer dans ce projet de
réforme des retraites et nous
parlementaires les enrichissons à ce
titre je veux saluer l'adoption en
commission des affaires sociales de
l'amendement de notre collègue
Marie-Pierre rexin qui vise
l'intégration dans l'index senior d'une
distinction par sexe et qui contrat
d'apporter davantage de donner genre de
manière à ce que les pouvoirs publics
puissent mieux identifier les solutions
à pouvoir mettre en place notamment pour
les femmes seniors c'est justement sur
cette question des données Henri que je
souhaiterais vous interroger ma collègue
Sandrine Josso et moi-même nous sommes
vus confiés par notre délégation droit
des femmes une mission d'information sur
le budget en Ré ou encore appelé budget
sensible aux gens malgré les efforts mis
en place lors du dernier quinquennat
notre pays dispose encore d'un certain
retard près de enfin on est bien loin
derrière de nombreuses nations membres
de l'OCDE qui ont déjà largement plus
initiés cette politique de budget
sensible aux gens lors de nombreuses
auditions que nous avons menées nous
avons pu constater la nécessité
d'apporter davantage de statistiques
genrées et d'informations chiffrées au
sein des pouvoirs publics pour permettre
une meilleure évaluation de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes mais
aussi de l'impact des finances publiques
sur cette égalité ainsi je souhaiterais
savoir dans quelle mesure au delà de
l'index égalité professionnelle ou
au-delà du futur index senior les
remontées d'informations sexuelles sont
d'ores et déjà mises en place au sein de
mystère et pas par ailleurs
pourriez-vous nous faire part de vos
réflexions sur la systématisation de la
récolte des données distinguant le sexe
pour les champs relevant de votre
ministère je vous remercie merci
Monsieur le Ministre peut-être en
demande d'avoir pour dire que
l'amendement mais je l'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure l'amendement à l'initiative de
Madame Rixens qui a fait l'objet d'un
avis favorable en commission sur le
caractère jean-ré des indicateurs et de
la manière dont on sera construit
l'index au seniors et est un amendement
pour lequel le gouvernement donner un
avis favorable considérons que c'est
utile et cela renvoie d'ailleurs à
l'intervention de Madame capot ça
permettra d'avoir quelque chose de plus
efficace en termes de maintien dans
l'emploi et de lutte pour l'égalité
professionnelle femme c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose pour vous dire
que sur la question du budget
ça échappe désormais à mes compétences
mais j'ai bien en tête les difficultés
méthodologiques qu'on avait rencontré il
est maintenant quelques années pour le
faire et l'objectif que nous avions
alors était de voir quels étaient dans
toutes les politiques publiques lorsque
j'étais en charge des comptes publics
dans des lignes de dépenses comme dans
les lignes de recettes ou de dépenses
fiscales quels étaient les impacts en
matière d'égalité professionnelle comme
on essaye aussi de les mesurer sur des
questions liées à l'environnement et la
protection de l'environnement les
données dont nous disposons au ministère
ont un caractère genre dans la plupart
des cas mais il est encore un énorme
travail à faire compris sur les
remontées d'information dont nous
disposant dans des cas plus collectifs
dès lors que les informations qui nous
remontent échappent à des scènes
d'information assez élaborées comme la
DS7 ne sont pas toujours
accompagnés
ça fait partie des sujets sur lesquels
on peut je crois progresser et si votre
mission d'information nous permet
d'avoir quelques pistes on sera aussi
très preneur
je vous remercie la parole est à Sophie
panenacle
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
ministre chien tout d'abord à vous
remercier vous et votre équipe pour
votre écoute et la prise en compte ou
pas d'ailleurs mais ça nous verrons plus
tard de nos demandes
vous l'avez dit au delà de l'égalité
salariale qui est le premier levier
d'action cette réforme nous donne dès
aujourd'hui l'opportunité d'améliorer la
retraite la situation des femmes et un
des dispositifs intéressants proposés
par ce projet de loi et l'assurance
vieillesse du parent au foyer
aujourd'hui les aidants pour bénéficier
de l'AVPF doivent assumer la charge
d'une personne en situation de handicap
enfant de moins de 20 ans ou adulte de
leur famille présentant au moins 80%
d'incapacité permanente on pourrait
d'ailleurs peut-être envisager passer à
moins que 80%. ils doivent également
avoir une activité professionnelle
réduite ou être sans activité
actuellement les périodes validées au
titre de la VPF ne sont pas prises en
compte ni pour les carrières longues ni
dans le 4 dans le cadre pardon de la
retraite animal après la réforme dans
les deux cas jusqu'à 4 trimestres
pourront être comptabilisés c'est une
réelle mesure de justice sociale
toutefois 4 trimestres monsieur le
ministre c'est encore peu alors que les
femmes consacrent en moyenne 14
trimestres à assumer cette charge aussi
je vous propose d'augmenter le nombre de
trimestres au titre pré au titre de la
VPF de 4 à 8 à la fois pour les
carrières longues et la retraite
minimale je vous remercie merci Monsieur
le Ministre merci Madame la
présidentiaux sur les questions
relatives à la VPF et notamment
la question de l'assurance vieillesse
par un foyer sur le dispositif carrière
longue nous allons intégrer comme vous
l'avez dit 4 trimestres en cohérence
avec d'autres périodes je pense
notamment en période de maladies ou
d'invalidité et ça permettra de
faciliter le départ en carrière longue
pour un grand nombre de bénéficiaires
nous allons faire la même chose pour ce
qui concerne la retraite minimale
puisque c'est trimestre seront pris en
compte dans le my mesurer c'est à dire
considéré comme équivalent cotisé ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui ce qui
permettra de faciliter l'accès à la
retraite minimale pour des assurés
souvent des femmes qui ont sinon des
toutes petites pensions du fait de temps
conséquent consacrés à leur famille et
aux enfants nous allons devoir fixer là
aussi un plafond pour la prise en compte
de trimestre valider au titre de la VPF
dans le calcul de l'éligibilité à la
carrière minimale et extra très
certainement supérieur à 4 trimestres de
manière à être plus protecteur que dans
le cadre du dispositif carrière longue
pour lequel nous souhaitons plutôt une
articulation avec les autres dispositifs
de validation de trimestre pour ce qui
concerne les aidants la piste que nous
avons ouverte aujourd'hui est autour de
4 là aussi par cohérence mais il est
vrai que la période consacrée à être
aidant et beaucoup plus longue en
moyenne et donc nous devons regarder et
nous sommes tout prêt à regarder comment
augmenter le nombre de trimestres qui
seraient prise en compte dans un
dispositif comme les carrières longues
ou le minimum contributif dans
spécifique des aidants tels que vous
l'avez décrit il y a un instant
je vous remercie la parole pardon est à
Brigitte l'ISO
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre j'avais prévu de vous poser une
question sur le l'index senior jean-ré
mais je crois que vous y avez
parfaitement répondu et vous avez validé
l'amendement de ma collègue Marie Pierre
Rixens je vais donc réorienter ma
question juste quand même peut-être
préciser que l'indice INSEE définit
l'emploi senior entre 54 et 64 ans mais
il me semble que pour les femmes ça
débute un peu avant c'était juste une
précision peut-être
pas très objective mais dans les
entreprises en tout cas ça se passe
comme ça donc ma question sera plutôt
sur les les clubs sportifs
professionnels je pense en particulier
au football mais pas seulement mais
étant les loises bien sûr je pense au
LOSC n'empêcherait pas de faire ce petit
clin d'œil c'est une entreprise qui ont
souvent plus de 300 300 personnels
n'envisage pas la possibilité de pouvoir
inclure les sportifs de haut niveau
professionnel dans cet index senior
merci je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre une question peut-être une
réponse pardon à madame la députée à
deux niveaux d'abord il y a parfois des
évidences qui s'imposent lorsqu'on est
face à des situations très très
particulières comme celle des clubs de
sport professionnels on sait très bien
que l'effectif professionnel a du mal à
être un effectif seniors c'est triste
pour tous ceux qui pratiquent mais c'est
malheureusement comme cela donc
évidemment qu'il y aura un examen au cas
par cas et qu'il faut faire attention à
ce type de situation très particulière
par contre votre question m'amène à
souligner un deuxième point dans le
cadre de la construction de l'index au
seniors nous sommes convaincus qu'il
faut laisser la possibilité je dis bien
la possibilité non pas l'obligation aux
branche professionnelle de se saisir des
indicateurs et des critères et avoir la
possibilité des adapter alors situation
démographique
indépendamment ou en tout cas au-delà
des cas très particuliers de club de
sport professionnels que vous avez
évoqué il y a des branches
professionnelles qui parlera d'activité
ce caractérise par une part de seniors
aujourd'hui qui est extrêmement plus
importante que les autres secteurs
professionnels il faut tenir compte de
ces points de départ différents si on
veut construire un index qui est de la
pertinence et qui donne des résultats
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à Émilie Chandler
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues ma question
concerne l'emploi des femmes dans les
territoires ruraux monsieur le ministre
ma question porte sur la surprise dans
les activités d'hébergement
médico-social et action sociale sans
hébergement dans ces territoires elles
sont 19,8% milieu rural c'est 8,4 points
de plus qu'en milieu urbain et où elles
sont réparties de manière plus homogène
selon les catégories de professions
cette sur-représentation n'est pas sans
poser de questions puisque l'on peut
lire une forme de résignation de la part
des femmes qui ne font pas toujours le
choix de ses emplois sur le ministre
dans l'agenda rural présenté en 2019 la
place des femmes était marginale
notamment en matière d'emploi je
souhaiterais donc savoir quelles sont
les mesures envisagées pour prendre en
compte sa spécificité du travail des
femmes dans le milieu rural et comment
la réforme envisagée apporte-t-elle une
réponse à ce sujet si elle existe
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
merci de la présidente la réforme de
retraite non parce que c'est un peu plus
éloigné de ce chant par contre nous
travaillons sur un autre aspect à notre
projet que le chantier qu'on appelait
France travail avec la volonté de
réorganiser ça fait d'ailleurs écho
madame capot évoqué tout à l'heure avec
un intention particulière à l'emploi des
femmes et des seniors et passionnants
des femmes seigneurs dans les
territoires l'objectif est d'avoir une
très très bonne coordination des acteurs
de l'emploi public en priorité mais
aussi privé s'appuyer sur y compris les
associations des appuis sur l'ensemble
des réseaux et d'avoir une gouvernance
qui soit territoriale possible pour que
les priorités d'action en matière
d'accès à l'emploi d'accès à la
formation maintien dans l'emploi de
perspective professionnelle soit adapté
de territoire par territoire et il n'y a
aucun doute à vision en tout cas dans
mon esprit que dans les territoires les
plus ruraux ces questions genre
finalement ou de surprésentation de tel
ou tel sexe dans la composition de
démographique d'un métier doivent être
prises en compte mais on va plutôt leur
envoyer à une gouvernance territoriale
et avec le souhait que les interco les
missions locales des départements et
régions y compris au titre de leurs
compétences d'insertion de leurs
compétences de formation soit capable
mais ça je n'ai pas d'autres non plus de
se mettre autour de la table et d'avoir
des réponses très spécifiques à ces
questions-là sur chacun des territoires
et ça renvoie aussi d'ailleurs
indépendamment du secteur de
l'hébergement médico-social que vous
avez évoqué c'est un renvoie aussi aux
difficultés qu'on rencontre en matière
de mobilité de logement et de garde
d'enfants puisque ça a été évoqué à
plusieurs reprises qui ne trouveront pas
de solution un véritablement efficace à
un niveau totalement national mais
plutôt un niveau local en faisant en
sorte que les bons acteurs représentants
se mettent d'accord sur les priorités et
sur la manière d'avancer
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
nous arrivons au terme de cette audition
il me reste à vous saluer vous remercier
infiniment de vous être prêté à notre
demande de réponse systématique à nos
questions je sais pas chers collègues
comment vous avez vécu cette audition à
titre personnel je trouvais ça
extrêmement dynamique et très plaisant
avec un ministre qui maîtrise bien ces
sujets donc c'est très agréable pour
nous
peut-être en tout cas pour ma part acté
cette notion de vouloir éradiquer cette
différence de pension entre les femmes
et les hommes à l'horizon d'une
génération dire que pour nous ça nous
donne l'opportunité de travailler sur un
peut-être futur projet de loi liés au
travail avec ces trois causes que
j'évoquais
au démarrage à savoir l'égalité
finalement salariale continuer de
travailler sur le sujet
l'accessibilité à des métiers sur
lesquels les femmes vont peut-être moins
et qui sont très rémunérateur et enfin
travailler sur le fait qu'elle travaille
plus finalement lié à leur maternité
parentalité et leur choix familiaux en
tant qu'aidante donc vous pourrez
compter sur notre délégation droit des
femmes pour faire des propositions et et
donner des éléments en tout cas pour
structurer ce temps de travail pour les
femmes qui sera je suis certaine des
avancées importantes merci à vous il me
reste à vous donner rendez-vous mercredi
15 février à 16h30 pour l'audition de
Madame la Ministre Agnès Firmin
lobaudeau Merci à VOUS bonne soirée